if you're planning to hit the road this
holiday weekend experts say check your
car the heat can take a toll on your
vehicle and the repairs could cost you
thousands of dollars
always look
under the car for leaks especially in
coolant a simple step Oscar Rodriguez
says anyone can do before they hit the
road this Labor Day weekend his auto
body shop near Desert Inn and Valley
View tends to get swamped for repairs
for heat problems that he says are
avoidable make sure all your fluids on
the engine compartment like engine
coolant for the radiator transmission
fluid make sure all the fluids are good
make sure all the hoses they're not
cracked ignoring these tips can cost you
last year about 500 000 roadside
assistance requests were made during the
Labor Day weekend across the country
according to AAA and that number is only
expected to go up we've all seen those
gas prices at record highs All Summer
Long gas prices are going down now which
might make it a little easier for people
to travel but even with the high prices
all summer people have been taking
vacations
AAA says be smart and plan ahead fill up
and get your card checked out before
your trip to avoid problems on the road
also check your tires Rodriguez says not
having enough air can be dangerous and
many times overlooked the biggest
problem that I have honestly is people
uh wouldn't do they don't do the right
service
and when it comes to your car in this
heat mechanics tell us your battery and
your brakes suffer the most batteries
expire more often and the heat can
actually cause rotors to wrap in some
cases